hello and welcome to this video playing
Alexander criminate ski creamy net ski
okay so we'll see what we get here yeah
it's early g3 it's an interesting move
water
you generally angle to get a Catalan but
avoid some of the sharp or continuations
affords a bit odd okay anyway it's
really good on f4 yeah probably take it
it just does not look very scary for
Blackie this whole thing what about
Knight g4 isn't that just good for me
yeah just get the bishop pair one what's
happening here is five chief g5 maybe II
five there is a knight b3 which doesn't
really matter I can take one of two so
yeah
now p3p should have to rock f2 night f2
king of to eat x f4 wins an exchange
I mean you played everything instantly
and it's now completely lost as they
tend to do it
okay the Queen takes on d5 and they
didn't have this move on the agenda at
all okay if I take everything like take
on F form
hmm I don't have an I don't have extra
material and it is kind of remarkable
okay um
I can't play Queen b6 and this is
probably best as it threatens maid I
with night h3 okay so he saves this he
saves against the maid okay if I check
on h3 I'm saving this one first okay so
he just accepts being an exchange down
would you probably had to do I mean I
didn't see anything particularly better
and now I say anything better than whoop
cheeks be true from not than winning
winning the pawns here checking first
yeah push the King in the corner should
be should be a good way of playing now
if he would move the knight I have Luke
takes a 4 mm in most cases we should be
four no pushes the pawn okay b3
intending rook a - yeah it must be okay
I could have taken a 6 actually that
would have been a bit better but ok it
was winning not quite clearly anyway in
all of those cases where the opponent
thinks the opening is unimportant and
Janis lost after 12 moves never get that
really why is that also so simple
yeah bishop waveform it cannot be
terrible but it's kind of it's not
really right on a for inspiration anyway
ok 96 he took it which is cannot be
critical really something like so we c4
c3 looks more interesting yeah I'm happy
to take on c5 in one go so my
development gets accelerated 95 yeah
just lose this time and 92 thing loses
the game almost or maybe there's some
odd way to equalize but it's just a
charitable move the bishop on e5 is in
it's not stable anyway and you have to
take care of it and now you don't really
have anything good available they
actually found a good defense so that is
the tricky defense
um yeah Bishop f4 after that it's lost
9p three losses upon yeah this is the
thing this is maybe objectively better
according to the engine but just to pawn
up sorry for that pawn up for nothing
yeah winning and I probably could have
won in it more clear matter here Queen F
could be six a stronger but winning this
is winning will be six and I found which
is not difficult found a winning
continuation yeah like it's just
completely completely winning of course
bouquet six is even stronger because he
cannot take this would be one checkmate
you
yeah it's not much to say I mean just
what I keep repeating and repeating
people pay no attention sometimes to the
opening moves just play whatever and
then I lost against decent play
he was the first time he thought he was
lost and I mean if you have no no real
knowledge as it was obvious here that
you can I mean if you know every move
play it of course but if you have no
idea and it was obvious he had no idea
and you have to think of it and then you
can play decently in the opening I've
had I've met many people over the years
a teammate once really had no clue about
the opening and he was a really really
strong international master and his
opening knowledge was absolutely close
to zero but he was when he was playing a
classical time control game he would sit
there and think and anyone would invest
two or three minutes even in the early
stage of the game and he would find very
good moves it is of course possible for
a strong player to find and the good
news but if you play instantly and you
have no clue you will lose against the
good player mostly out of the opening
thanks a lot for watching